dans le cadre de sa stratégie des
marchés publics québec veut prioriser
les achats de biens de services
québécois par les organismes publics
d'ici 2026 les acquisitions de biens
québécois seront augmentés de 1 milliard
500 millions de dollars on en parle avec
sonia noël qui est la ministre
responsable de l'administration
gouvernementale et la présidente du
conseil du trésor bonsoir madame lebel
bonsoir alors comment
comptez vous rendre les marchés publics
comme ça
assez rapidement beaucoup plus
accessible aux pme
mais oui le plus rapidement possible je
pensais peut-être bon juste de prendre
une question de contexte pour commencer
vous savez il ya trois grands secteurs
où les marchés publics agissent on parle
des secteurs la construction vous avez
mentionné libyen est mentionné les
services quand on parle construction et
de services plus de 95 % des achats
gouvernementaux des investissements
gouvernementaux se font au québec quand
pour des retombées au québec là où on
avait je lui dirai peut-être un déficit
de retomber c'est vraiment content quand
on parle de l'acquisition des biens ou
la part des marchés du marché de nos
marchés publics qui était réservé août
est attribuée plutôt mon entreprise
québécoise était d'environ 38% alors
c'est vraiment dans ce secteur qu'on
veut augmenter de 10% ce qui équivaut ou
1.5 milliard à terre neuve au terme de
stratégie venez de mentionner et environ
530 millions par année donc on va le
faire encore de quelle façon en
exploitant le plus possible d'émargement
deux qui sont disponibles pour le
gouvernement du québec et nos
entreprises sont sous les accords de
libéralisation du marché naturellement
très importante de mentionner qu'on ne
peut pas fermer au marché parce que nos
entreprises veulent avoir des contrats
publics à l'extérieur du québec donc je
pense que ça fait partie des accords
donc de garder nos marchés ouverts pour
les entreprises extérieures et quels
sont justement vos marges de manoeuvre
madame lebel sans venir altérer les
marchés extérieurs
compte tenu que les entreprises
québécoises veulent aussi participer aux
marchés publics extérieurs oui mais sous
main sur les marges de manoeuvre des
accords dont qui ne nous oblige pas
nécessairement à ouvrir à tous et à
l'extérieur on est capable de voir
comment on peut maximiser tout chaud
donc peut-être en faisant des haltes man
n'est qu'apparent n'est pas capable de
régionaliser certains appels d'offres on
a fait dernièrement dans des contrats
d'achat avec le centre d'exhibition
gouvernementale pour des masques entre
autres des masques à fenêtre on avait on
a été capable justement de réserver des
loups à des entreprises québécoises pour
des masques étaient fabriqués au québec
dont on est capable de le faire on m'a
laissé place à l'intérieur des accords
c'était une des stratégies compris en
exemple quand vous dites 38% 38% débit
des biens qui sont acquis sont au québec
46 % c'est ailleurs au canada est ce que
c'est la marge du canada vous voulez
baissé au profit des achats québécois
banques ont incidemment la marge du
canada c'est plutôt augmenter la marge
est retombé au québec naturellement
48%
c'est certain que on a peut-être un peu
moins d'espèces ou l'accord canadien
donc il faut encore une fois une
certaine marge qui va être quand même
devoir respecter la lettre les
compagnies canadiennes qui voudraient
soumissionner mais on se pense qu'on est
capable avec des marques démarche
préférentiel qu'on pourrait donner aussi
pour l'achat québécois n'en rajoutez pas
être une marche et elle a assez de 10%
vous pouvez la pop art devient québécois
à tous oui et sous les soulanes hargeisa
car il sait que le projet de loi la
stratégie et le projet de loi veut faire
également un et l'autre est l'autre
stratégie c'est maintenant c'est une
possibilité pour nos ministères et
organismes de le faire ce qu'on veut
faire maintenant c'est obligé dans le
cadre de la loi les ministères et
organismes de reconsidérer prioriser
l'achat québécois avant toute chose dont
d'intégrer cette priorité là et cet
objectif-là d'alors dans leur réflexion
sur les appels d'offres vous avez dit
aujourd'hui devant la chambre de
commerce du montréal métropolitain qu'il
faut acheter québécois chez des
fournisseurs présents chez nous des
fournisseurs présents chez nous donc une
entreprise américaine qui a une présence
au québec c'est acheter québécois
ont écouté la définition dans l'est de
la stratégie c'est d'avoir pignon sur
rue au québec naturellement c'est une
définition différente quand on parle de
l'achat québécois en termes de
fabrication québec donc oui mais ça peut
être amené à évoluer cette définition là
on travaille beaucoup avec le ministère
de l'économie pour voir comment on peut
préciser meilleure place dans la
stratégie pour venir préciser cette
définition là mais pour l'instant on
parle effectivement d'entreprises qui
ont pignon sur rue au québec quand on
parle d'entreprises québécoises pour lui
quand on va parler de marge de manoeuvre
et de tact hommage préférentiels pour la
chaux québécois naturellement des notes
des notions de fabrication au québec
dont une très bonne part importante vont
être respectés mais oui on a
certainement une certaine obligation
dans nos définitions offrait capable de
garder son nom marche super format mais
aussi de respecter tous les accords
en terminant madame lebel vous
travaillez fort ces jours ci vous
préparer le budget avec d'autres
collègues éric girard et les crédits
budgétaires n'est ce pas absolument et
sans nous révéler ce qu'il y aura dans
le budget est ce que vous pensez à cette
hausse tarifaire d'hydro-québec de plus
de 5% qui va toucher quand même les gens
compte tenu du changement législatif qui
a eu lieu au québec sous votre
gouvernement de passer d'une hausse des
tarifs une hausse des tarifs arrimé à
l'inflation mais on pense à toute prise
au ski sont dues à l'inflation à aux
impacts des onze de l'essence aux
impacts de la des hausses tarifaires en
matière d'hydroélectricité ont pas ou on
pense aussi à toutes les impacts de la
hausse en matière immobilière en matière
d'alimentation donc oui mon collègue qui
prépare plus particulièrement le budget
naturellement est très conscient de tout
cela et de l'impact l inflexion sur un
maillage québécois ayant très très
certainement des stratégies a présenté
dans le cadre j'ai eu ce qu'on attend
des transports en dévoiler plus est ce
que le gel des tarifs d'hydro-québec est
sur la table
pour l'instant le dire est que la
réflexion est plus sur une une remise
d'argent aux québécois ou aux familles
québécoises aux foyers québécois qui
sont dans des tranches qui en ont le
plus besoin naturellement il pas exclu
de réfléchir à une suite des choses
parce que on est très conscient que même
après le budget cette dissuasion qui
sera évolutive je sais qu'on aura on
pourra suivre la situation de très près
ce ajuste en conséquence mais ce qui est
privilégiée pour l'instant c'est de
remettre de l'argent aux gens pour être
capables à eux deux à quel endroit dans
le budget il a dâ et qu'elle se passe
que l'impact est pas le même on parle
effectivement terme d'essence
électricité bon alimentation ne pas tous
auquel on en jeu mais tout le monde
était vrai je dois vous arrêtez madame
lebel merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous un plaisir bonne soirée à tous